[Música]
chiles se preparan para una jornada
clave este domingo cuando millones de
ciudadanos están citados a las urnas
para un plebiscito en el que decidirán
si aprueban o rechazan la nueva
constitución que podría reemplazar a la
heredada de la dictadura de augusto
pinochet el país está polarizado entre
detractores y defensores del nuevo texto
llamo enemigo del estado al presidente
joe parte en los comentarios fueron
realizados en un mitin en pensilvania
donde días atrás el mandatario aseguró
que trump y algunos republicanos
representan un extremismo que amenaza
los cimientos de la república y la
cámara de diputados de argentina
continuo el intento de homicidio a la
vicepresidenta cristina fernández y
exigió exigió el esclarecimiento del
hecho pese al rechazo general la
votación demostró las tensiones
políticas en el país con el principal
partido opositor al gobierno retirándose
tras la votación del texto y el frente
de izquierda absteniéndose
hola bienvenidos a esta emisión
informativa de france 24 dedicada a las
principales noticias de américa y
santiago ariztía y comenzamos esta
emisión en chile porque los ciudadanos
de este país tienen una cita obligatoria
con las urnas este domingo para decidir
si aprueban o rechazan la nueva
constitución del país se trata del
capítulo final de una larga trama que
comenzó con el estallido social de 2019
y el camino para redactar el nuevo texto
estuvo marcado por polémicas y desafíos
y en los últimos meses primó una fuerte
campaña dividida entre detractores y
defensores del nuevo texto que dejaría
atrás a la carta magna- de 1980
promulgada durante la dictadura de
augusto pinochet
el estado plurinacional la coexistencia
de diversas naciones y pueblos en el
marco de la unidad del estado todos
estos tendrían el derecho a la autonomía
pero reitera que en ningún caso el
ejercicio de ésta podrá atentar en
contra del carácter único e indivisible
del estado de chile ni permitirá la
secesión territorial la democracia
paritaria 50 por ciento de todos los
órganos del estado tendrán que ser
ocupadas por mujeres según el artículo 6
del documento esto aplicaría incluso
para las empresas públicas además el
estado debería promover adoptar medidas
para alcanzar la igualdad de género el
sistema político de 35 a 30 años pasaría
a ser la edad mínima para postularse a
la presidencia un cargo para el que el
nuevo texto permite una reelección
consecutiva y no alternada como en la
actualidad
uno de los puntos inéditos en la
eliminación del senado de la república
este sería reemplazado por la cámara de
las regiones que estaría conformada por
al menos tres representantes de cada una
de las regiones del país así el poder
legislativo chileno pasaría de tener un
congreso nacional compuesto de la cámara
de diputados y el senado a tener un
congreso para la formulación de leyes y
una cámara de las regiones destinada a
revisar ciertas de las normas
derechos humanos la nueva carta magna
establece a chivas como estado social y
democrático de derecho con el deber de
proveer bienes y servicios para asegurar
los derechos de las personas resalta lo
expuesto con respecto a la educación la
define de carácter laico y gratuito
mientras que lo estipulado para los
derechos reproductivos ha generado
controversia se establece que deben ser
garantizadas las condiciones para un
embarazo una interrupción voluntaria del
mismo así como partos y paternidad
voluntarios y protegidos
y el expresidente de eeuu donald trump
llamó a su sucesor yobái de enemigo del
estado frente a sus seguidores reuniones
en un mitin de campaña de cara de las
elecciones de mitad de término en
pensilvania ante una multitud de trump
respondió a las palabras pronunciadas
por bailén gente sylvania días atrás
cuando aseguró que el exmandatario y los
republicanos de su línea make amerite
great en hacer eeuu grandes de nuevo en
español representan un extremismo que
amenaza los cimientos de la república si
bien vaivén aclaró que no se refería a
todos los republicanos esto dijo trump
al respecto
como saben esta semana joe biden vino a
filadelfia pensilvania para dar el
discurso más vicioso odioso y divisivo
jamás pronunciado por un presidente
estadounidense
en presente
vilipendio a 75 millones de ciudadanos y
probablemente a otros 75 a 150 si
queremos ser precisos al respecto
como amenazas a la democracia y enemigos
del estado todos ustedes son enemigos
del estado
él es un enemigo del estado el enemigo
del estado es el y el grupo que lo
controla
y en otras noticias un incendio forestal
en la zona rural del norte de california
en eeuu arrasó con un vecindario y
destruyó unas 100 viviendas y otros
edificios además al menos dos personas
resultaron heridas y miles se vieron
obligadas a abandonar sus hogares
el denominado meal fire comenzó por la
tarde del viernes sus llamas quemaron un
número significativo de viviendas y
muchos residentes tuvieron que huir para
salvar sus vidas y si bien las
condiciones climáticas mejoraron otro
incendio el mountain fire creció
sustancialmente
noticias de américa latina' a la cámara
de diputados de argentina condenó el
ataque del jueves pasado contra la
vicepresidenta cristina fernández si
exigió el esclarecimiento del hecho así
como también la condena a los
responsables pese al rechazo general a
la violencia
la votación se vio empañada por la
polarización política que atraviesa el
país el informe de jorge hurtado
las grietas están abiertas los diputados
argentinos rechazaron el ataque contra
cristina fernández durante una sesión
especial donde el texto final fue
aprobado por amplia mayoría
la honorable cámara de diputados de la
nación expresa su enérgico repudio al
intento de magnicidio contra la
vicepresidenta y dos veces presidenta de
la nación doctora cristina fernández de
kirchner cristina está viva pero podría
no estarlo la coalición gobernante
frente de todos propuso un texto donde
denunció que el ataque fue motivado por
los discursos de odio y las divisiones
se hicieron notar hay un punto de la
situación que vivimos que me parecen muy
importantes los tan trillados discursos
de odio existen los vemos en muchos
lugares los vemos repetidos los vemos
retransmitidos hay personas que son
habladas por ese odio aquellos que
hablan
discurso del odio no tienen la menor
idea lo que es un discurso del odio lean
la comisión americana de derechos
humanos artículo 3 inciso 5 lo que es el
discurso del odio al acá lo que hay
discrepancias políticas ideológicas
los diputados de propuesta republicana
partido del expresidente mauricio macri
abandonaron el hemiciclo y la izquierda
se abstuvo de votar javier mi ley líder
del partido de extrema derecha la
libertad avanza rompió el silencio que
mantenía tras el atentado no es otro
desde la libertad avanza dejamos claro
nuestro repudio a la violencia pero no
aceptamos de ninguna manera este circo
dantesco de la política muchas gracias
señora presidente
la defensa de fernández adelantó que
pedirá que la causa sea calificada como
un intento de femicidio mientras el
acusado se negó a declarar frente a las
autoridades y por segunda vez en la nasa
suspendió el lanzamiento del cohete que
busca llevar nuevamente al ser humano a
la luna directivo de la agencia espacial
dieron a conocer la nueva ventana de
lanzamiento en el mes de octubre a la
vez que se mostraron aliviados de que
sea en el período de pruebas que se
conozcan sus defectos su rafael perez
nos cuenta más
decepción entre los entusiastas del
espacio este fue el panorama que dejó la
segunda suspensión del lanzamiento de la
misión no tripulada artemis 13 día
estamos desanimados este es el segundo
intento de lanzamiento en el que hemos
estado esperábamos presenciar el
despegue de cerca pero aparentemente
están teniendo problemas con un tanque
esperemos que el tercer intento sea una
maravilla al momento de la cancelación
el director de la nasa bill nelson dejó
claras las intenciones de la interfaz ya
le
diremos cuando esté listo no iremos
hasta entonces y especialmente ahora en
un vuelo de prueba
porque vamos a enfatizar esto y probarlo
y probar este escudo térmico y
asegurarnos de que esté bien antes de
poner a cuatro humanos en el cohete así
que esto es parte del negocio espacial
esport de espais verds horas más tarde
la directiva de la misión dio a conocer
un nuevo periodo de lanzamiento acorde a
los cálculos de cercanías órbitas con la
luna y condiciones meteorológicas
wii con el período de lanzamiento 25
definitivamente está fuera de la mesa
no despegaremos saben que este periodo
termina el martes los periodos de
lanzamiento 26 y 27 realmente dependerán
de las opciones que tenga el equipo
probablemente el lunes o martes temprano
por la mañana hagan un mando
la falla técnica que pospuso el evento
consistió en la detección de una fuga de
hidrógeno líquido mientras se cargaba de
combustible la etapa central de la nave
la misión artemis 1 consiste en poner a
prueba las capacidades del cohete space
launch system portador de la cápsula
orion que llevara nuevamente al hombre a
la luna después de casi 50 años de la
última caminata en nuestro satélite
natural
hasta aquí esta emisión informativa
regresamos en breve con más noticias
sigan en france 24
[Música]